hey hello very good morning to you
and uh welcome to the sky news virtual
tour
my name is jamal fanville i'm a
presenter here
at sky news now over the next couple of
hours or so
we're going to be talking to people who
work right here at sky news
to ask them about their jobs and perhaps
most
importantly for you all to get an idea
of how they started their careers
in youth and then after that we'll put
some of your questions to a
very special panel people that work in
all
areas of the sky news business um
fingers crossed all your internet
connections will stay
up and running but if it does drop down
don't worry you can rejoin and we'll
let you back in um so before
we get going let me just tell you a
little bit about sky news
what we're about and what the plans are
for the future so
sky news we were set up more than 30
years ago
and we were the uk's first dedicated
24-hour
tv news channel since then we've got a
whole lot bigger
and that is because of the internet our
app
our websites we've got around four
million unique
users every day we're on snapchat we're
on
youtube we're on instagram and our
twitter account has
six million followers we also provide a
new service for
300 radio stations right across the uk
so that is a huge amount of news so
look this does beg the question what is
news how do we make news what is
newsworthy
and what isn't how do we go out and
about in
source news and how do we get that news
out to our audience our viewers you guys
sitting at home now the person that can
tell us
all about that is tyrone francis um he
is our senior editor
on the home news desk he's on duty today
hey tyrone
um what can you tell me about the home
desk how does it work
hello hoping you can hear me um so i am
one of the
home senior news editors on the news
desk here at sky
uh my job kind of just involves sorting
out the whole logistics
and making sure that the final product
that you see at home uh
is as polished as possible and all the
elements that
uh tell the story in the right way are
all in those
packages there's two minute news reports
that happen at the end of the day so
just
that's kind of my job is seeing what the
stories are and translating that into a
piece of television for later on on
tv so so do you decide the news stories
on your own tyrone or is it a team
effort are there meetings through the
day
so there's initial kind of thoughts that
i will come in in the morning and have i
mean this
news is divided into multiple different
segments you've got
news that's planned so we may know that
you know the queen might be having a
state visit and go into
you know parliament or something like
that we know that's going to happen
you've got breaking news which you which
happens and you've just got to react to
it maybe like a natural disaster
um so you know i i will come in with
some initial thoughts and then i'll have
a big discussion with
you know today in my 7 30 meeting there
was about over 25 to 30 people in that
meeting this morning
is there any such thing as a typical day
in use
no there is there isn't anything as a
typical day every day is different
and i think that's why i enjoy it so
much because you know i
walk into the newsroom i walk into the
office and you know it's
everything is a moving uh moving chess
pieces you know there's nothing that's
always set in stone you know you can
have fun with it that's the
biggest thing i can say about working in
news you can have fun because nothing is
not a
formulaic day the meetings might be
the same time each day but the stories
that we cover is just such a wide range
of stories
and that's a senior news editor you are
getting stories from all around the
country
so how do we decide what is newsworthy
and what isn't because there'll be a lot
of stories if you look at
the regional news um outfits you know
there's
lots of news around yes i mean
it's an interesting question you asked
there because you know we have a
regional network we have
teams that are based in the north west
in the northeast in birmingham
uh and in the western wales and it's
kind of
stories that matter to people i think
that's the thing that we try to do the
most
here at sky news is what stories affect
real people
uh in those communities and i think
that's you know if it's affecting people
then it's
it is a newsworthy story obviously
there's going to be times where there's
you know maybe crimes there might be you
know murders or
um you know different stories that
happen that we have to cover but i think
the the key thing is
is what stories matter to people
in their communities and that's how we
judge the stories on on that go on our
bulletin throughout the day
and how did you start off the news did
you always know that you wanted to be a
news editor
no i didn't actually um i always knew
that i wanted to work in tv i didn't
know that i wanted to work in news
um i kind of fell into news by accident
but you know as most people say you make
your own luck
i worked at the olympics in 2012 uh
working for the olympic broadcasting
services
and that was in my second year at
university so in the middle of
of doing university and um i started
talking to a sports reporter because i
was interested in sports and you know
after a 10-minute conversation
you know he invited me into the itv
newsroom which is where i
uh started off my career um
and then i started doing some work
experience you know doing all the kind
of
you know we call it phone bashing but
just putting in all the calls making
sure that we can try and set up
little bits elements for other reporters
or research essentially
and um you know i stayed there long
enough that they couldn't really get rid
of me
and i stayed there for six years uh and
the rest is history um as they say
and what makes a a good news editor
oh good question i i would hope to think
that i am one of them um
i think absolutely i think i think key
to being
a a good senior news editor is having a
good rapport
with uh people out in the field because
you know those are your
those are those are the people that are
delivering the stories you know to a
high
high quality the content that they're
going to get and you have to be a good
communicator because
you know as i said to you earlier we
have meetings where there's lots of
different opinions lots of different
voices that are trying to uh you know
have an input in how the story should be
told
but you know my job is to speak to the
reporter the producer out in the field
who are going to be telling the story
and you know kind of filtering as
the information that they need to know
is that they could go and because if
you're they're bombarded with about
10 different suggestions or ideas and
the focus is kind of lost there
i think the key thing for being a good
news editor seeing your news editor on
the news desk
is being able to uh listen to all the
information that's being had
in the conversations in the meetings and
then filtering that down to the
reporters
and producers okay tyree thank you very
much i know you've got a busy day ahead
of you in fact just before you go
what what stories are we covering today
oh um there's quite a lot of stories i
mean
on the home front um katarina who i can
see is just joined the zoom
call i've just deployed her to go to uh
pendle in north west
uh she's going to be looking at a story
where people
who are on low incomes uh are said that
if they have to quarantine they will
get 13 pounds a day or 183 pounds
a month by the government if they are
out of pocket
um what else are we looking at we are
looking at the sad
really sad story of a um
a woman in scotland who sadly
passed away and we are seeing whether we
can speak to
her partner who is now looking after
their one-year-old son so we've sent a
correspondent to scotland
uh but there's loads of foreign around
you you might you know after this you
can
turn on screens and you'll see there's
louisiana um
there's hurricane laura there's lots of
happening lots happening in the state so
there's so much between
uh what i do on the home desk and the
foreign desk as well to make sure that
we provide the best content
hey tyrion as i said i'll let you go
you're definitely very busy
many thanks indeed for your time and
guys and just remember
we will be asking your questions after
11 o'clock so do start typing them in
by the q and a function now i want to
get as many questions
and there's humanly possible because
you've got a really great panel an
interesting panel
and they would love to hear what you
have to say and they would love to
answer your questions so
moving on from tyrone and over to
katarina who's
um in the field hey katarina how are you
doing what are you
working on today yeah good morning well
as tyrone said this is actually a very
good way for him to check up though i'm
actually where he
initially deployed me isn't it so i'm um
a siren said i'm a
pendle which uh is an area of lancashire
which has
um been under stricter quarantine
coronavirus lockdown measures because of
the number of cases here being
a higher relative to the other bits of
the country
and we're looking at how um the
government's announced today that it's
going to help support people on lower
incomes
when they need to self-isolate so we're
sort of coming to pendleton to see how
that is going to
go down with people here lots of people
already saying it it's far too little
and isn't going to
make an impact but i think it's quite
interesting isn't it you've already seen
kind of how
how the chain of command works a little
bit from tyrone and having that initial
very early morning planning meeting then
filtering it through um to us on the
ground
us deploying to where we need to go and
you know from from now on until
7pm we'll be speaking to people
gathering interviews
working out the best way to tell the
story and you work with the team on the
ground can you introduce them to
us oh you know i would do but they're
not yet
sorry it's live breaking news they're
still on their way
but actually what i will do is i'll show
you that um
as much as we work with a really big
team
sometimes it really is about being
flexible about being lighter foot and
i'm going to show you my
my sturdy reporters kit which uh
first it's you live in your car as a
reporter but you also
uh get a field microphone
and that means that wherever i am
anytime i can
record a piece of um audio track
which i then can send by the internet
down to our base in london
uh with this little ipad and at the
moment of course you wouldn't be a
reporter in the field working on
any story uh without your trusty face
mask this one's got a filter so it's
extra robust so that we're
totally safe when we're out and about
obviously lots of hand sanitizer as well
but
normally we would be working in a team
uh
with a camera crew sometimes you'll also
be working with a field producer who
will either be
out with you on location um or they'll
be back at base putting in phone calls
phone bashing getting those sort of best
voices that we can to the piece that
when we're
on the ground when we're always time
poor there's never enough time you'll
know that
we're always working to a tight deadline
and
you know you can really make sure you're
getting the best interviews sort of
as fast as you can often because yeah we
always wish that news would be ready for
tomorrow but it's always now and it's
always yesterday so you're always
working to a tight deadline
absolutely and katrina how did you get
into
tv news reporting is this something that
you always wanted to do
well i always knew i wanted to be in
journalism i
um started off in radio just my local
radio station
um i didn't have a
a journalism specific degree but i knew
it was something i wanted to do
uh so i ended up working at my local
radio station as like the
absolute junior junior juno you could
possibly be
and um at the time i was also doing um
like a remote learning all sort of the
media law
side of things so that i kind of had
that kind of you know
that background as well um and then it
was a very very long
path to kept working in tv news
i kind of went slightly sideways because
i went into sports broadcasting
and i don't know if i should say this
but it just i don't want people to feel
discouraged if they apply for
traineeships and don't get them
because i applied to this guy news
traineeship at least three times
and i never got it um but here i am
i got in through somewhere else uh so
yes i
went through sports broadcasting then i
went and worked overseas for a tv news
channel
and then uh wow you know now what am i
and back at sky news where i always knew
i should be in the first place
absolutely so the hard work does pay off
what tips would you give and people
who really want to become news reporters
in the future
i think the thing to remember about news
is that
it's extremely hard work you've got to
be persistent
you've got to keep knocking at the door
if if that first
you know email to someone about work
experience doesn't work
follow up with that person if you meet
someone out and about who's got a camera
and they say oh yeah you know keep it
maybe you should keep feel free to keep
in contact with me
keep in contact with that person um and
also i think
just if you've got the ideas and you've
got the story ideas
you know those are things really to work
on sometimes i think people get
almost too fixated on where i should be
tell it where i should be working what i
should be doing versus actually what are
the stories i want to be telling because
that i think if you know what stories
you want to tell that can often help
navigate and help dictate you know where
you could be working to tell those
stories it might not be a
traditional tv news broadcaster like sky
news it could be something online it
could be a digital outlet you know i
think there's
what's brilliant about starting out now
which perhaps didn't really exist when
you and i were starting
is that there is a lot more ways for
people to tell stories
online digitally tv news radio
all sorts of different multimedia
aspects so actually i think it's a
really really exciting time to be
starting out because there's just so
much opportunity
and it feels like it is a lot more
accessible and it's a lot more diverse
and i think if you know what stories you
want to tell and you can tell them well
you know that should be what leads you
when you want to try and start out
okay i'm going to put you on the spot
now katarina what's the best thing about
the job and what's the worst thing about
it
oh worst thing about it
very long days and sometimes you can't
always find a loo
so that is the hazard of being a field
reporter
um best thing about it the variety
meeting amazing people
and there is such an incredible thrill
when you see a story that you've written
go out and you see it's having an impact
and people responding to it
people not only who've been affected by
the issue but even people in senior
government
and you think are you a you know could
what you do
affect a real change and that honestly
is the most incredible feeling
okay again busy day ahead of you good to
chat
thank you yeah likewise thank you bye
guys so remember we really want your
question we've got that very special
panel who want to
hear what you have to say hear what you
have to ask them they would
love to answer those questions so do
keep typing using that q a function
we will aim to answer as many questions
as we can at
11 o'clock now all our correspondents
just like katharina are expected to be
multi-media journalists reported for
telly
the radio the website and of course for
this sky news app but we also have a
dedicated digital reporter alex carlston
is one of them and she's in the newsroom
hey how are you
um tell us about your job hi kamal
um so i write for whatever you see on
the
sky news website and also on our app
and so if you have the app and you see
the push notifications coming through
and there's breaking news
um we do that all here in the newsroom
and
um it involves a lot of kind of
looking around for stories and also um
we have
lots of our correspondents out and about
as well they bring in stories for us
and it is quite different to tv because
we can do
really different stories from them um
because
we don't have the constraints of having
to film it
um we can just use pictures and stuff
that we get from all the picture
agencies
or we even get um pictures and videos
from members of the public
um who might be at the scene of say a
fire
or or we get stories from them
and so it's a really wide variety of
things that we do
so what makes a good digital story what
should suddenly be thinking when they go
out and about they're doing a bit of
filming
and they want to become a digital
reporter
well we cover so many different types of
stories and you know very serious ones
obviously all the politics stories but
you know it's really about
getting down to the people what do
people
um what are people interested in how
will a story affect them
and as katharina said you always want a
story
to really get down to the person and
if you can help somebody then that is an
amazing
feeling and that is kind of why every
journalist gets into it isn't it
um but we all but there are also
you know kind of stories of panda bears
being born who doesn't love that
um that is a great digital story
in contrast with all the serious things
so it really is
such a varied um scope stories
and what can you tell us about your
career how did you start off and also
what tips can you give somebody
so i started off i finished university i
did politics
and i didn't really want to do
a whole other year of of education
doing a masters in journalism but then i
did a couple of
internships and stuff which was really
difficult to get i just kind of
wrote to everyone um and i was lucky
because i
lived in hong kong so i basically it's a
lot small at the pool there so i
literally just knocked on doors and said
give me some work experience i'll work
for free um but eventually i found that
it was really hard to get
a job um in the uk especially without
any kind of
journalism training so i did the press
association course which is
um four months it's crammed into
or you do absolutely everything it was
amazing and then i went on to a local
paper
um and my patch was actually right here
in eiserworth
um and then i went on to i learned so
much from that because you just get sent
out
and you have to just find your own
stories which is
probably the best training you can ever
get um
and it gives you so much confidence if
you're shy you just have to get over it
basically
um you cover every type of story from
you get getting the price of tea down at
the local leisure center
to big murder trials um
so it really was great and then i went
on to a tabloid paper to the daily
express which was also
really good training and then i've been
here for three years which is great
accuracy and impartiality is so
important for the work that we do
how do you remain on track it really is
um so we are constantly thinking about
the
legal issues that we might um come
across from a story
and and that's something that you kind
of you learn through your training and
through
on the job and also you know being
accurate with your facts
is so crucial because that's why people
come to read the news they want the
facts
and especially in this day and age where
we have fake news bandied around all the
time
we have to be so careful and that we get
everything accurate
um and we have to triple check sources
and triple check everything we've
written
um not just for accuracy and facts and
legal things but also for typos and
things like that
i would say one of the best tips i have
ever had is
just reread your story multiple times
over and
never just even if you're in a rush and
you have to get it out
it is so worth just rereading it again
because then you won't make mistakes
and are you constantly hungry for news
alex or did you find time to give
yourself a break
um i have to admit that i just
constantly am reading the news
and looking out for stories and i've
even managed to train some of my friends
you know tell them what a story is and
they've come they'll come to me with a
story
that took quite a while um but yeah i
i think for most journalists i'm sure
you're the same grammar you're always
you see something and you immediately
think is that a story oh that could be
really good
um you know i think this this is a real
issue we need
to attack and help out um people who
you know this isn't out there and we
could help yeah so
so what story is he covering today um
so today i've actually been doing a lot
of trump um
he um yeah he's he's kind of really
ramping up the campaign
for the uh uh to be president and um
tomorrow he's making his big address um
when he officially accepts the
presidential nominee
and he um he's obviously on the attack
against joe biden
so um we're doing a lot about that
and so you can see we do so many
different stories from the us to the uk
to
absolutely all around the world doesn't
matter where it is
alex we'll let you go many thanks indeed
for your time well from
digital to the world of tv we're going
to take you now to our head of studios
um a guy called
ben wickham he is in charge of well
how would you describe it um ben what is
the gallery
and what do you do when you're sat in
so uh thanks kemal um so what is the
gallery what do i do what
i'm saying so my job really is to um run
the team
uh run the gallery as it works while i
run the team of directors um anyone who
knows anything about television knows
there's many many things happen um in
in any kind of program there's all sorts
of graphics there's video tapes there's
there's live things that you know
there's
there's various things happen anything
that's pre-recorded that gets that stuff
will get put together in an edit suite
um the great thing about live tv is that
we effectively knit that whole thing
together
um live as it's coming in so what you
can see behind me here is lots and lots
of screens
uh they've got graphics they've got uh
incoming sources you would
you spoke to katarina earlier uh she
will be on an outside source somewhere
she's reporting or should be on a camera
in the newsroom yourself you'll be in
the camera
in the studio possibly with guests like
i said all sorts of graphic sources
and feeds from reuters and aptn all
these various things um
the team that i run the directors will
sit in the middle of that so they will
consult with the program editor
who will have who created the editorial
for that show and then we make it
effectively make it into tv we make it
to the thing you see so there'll be the
people telling the sound operators the
camera operators what they want
making sure the graphics appear at the
right time making sure that the right
things happen at the right time
essentially and
crucially as you know talk to yourself
or your your colleagues who will be
uh to make sure that you know what's
happening obviously we will all discuss
this before the show
but so you know what's happening uh and
so we can calmly
navigate through that show and make sure
it all goes on air okay
it's obviously a very high-quality
environment um how do you cope what are
your tips
uh i always think the trick the trick
with them working in a gallery well
working on live television anyway i mean
it's um
i always i've said to you i said before
we we're a bit like adrenaline junkies i
think we've sat in that room so often
and you've sat in front of a camera so
often we don't even notice how stressful
it is
but it is stressful um but the key is
and this is the thing i always say when
i
whenever i am whenever i train new
directors or anyone that works in any
field of
live tv you always have to have a plan
you always have to be one step ahead of
the program um whether that's an
incredibly tightly
uh organized kind of bulletin that's got
you know perfectly run to time or where
you're in some sort of a breaking news
situation
whatever you're doing you're thinking
one step ahead or hopefully you're
thinking two or three steps ahead
so uh anything at any point can just
disappear on your cameras can go down
live shots can go down
videotapes can stop i mean god bless
even uh presenters can sometimes have a
you know have a coughing fit or whatever
at any point whatever you're doing we
could stop so we have to be ready to
jump to the next thing and jump to the
next thing if that's not ready you jump
to the thing after that and you're
trying to
you're always keeping ahead of yourself
um i think as long as you've got a plan
b and a plan c and a plan d
uh you can generally be quite calm in a
gallery environment yeah i know you're
standing outside any chance of being
able to show us what goes on inside
i would love to show you what's going on
just so just to give you an idea where
we are at the moment i'm standing uh in
the middle of the newsroom
you can see behind me this is where all
the kind of journalism happens this is
where all the various things
come in um but let me take you inside
the gallery i'll see if i can switch
this around
our sky news gallery is right in the
heart
of the sky news center and here we go
so this is the live tv output at the
moment here we have
this stuff doing sound here um the owner
at the back there is
uh running the that she's the technical
supervisor for the gallery she's making
sure everything works okay
sam here is the program editor she's the
one who's put whole editorial
prospect together and then dan you'll
see here
is directing the main app and choosing
all of those sources
and making sure they all happen at the
right time telling sarah what's going on
telling ian what's going on
and basically making sure that what
you're seeing on tv is clean
it's accurate it's uh timely uh and
working okay
now i'm just gonna quietly sneak more
out of it
let's go back to talking to you yeah and
ben how did you start off in your career
um
so i had a slightly uh securities route
really i think i was um
i i didn't study anything to do with
television at university i saw actually
someone was talking earlier about um
community uh working tv with a geography
degree i actually did do a geography
degree
and then whilst i was at university i
got involved in a few shoots for the
university
and then through that got involved with
some production companies and and
basically fell in love with television i
fell in love with live television um
i initially wanted to work on kind of
saturday night shows and then i thought
no actually you know those those
are fun shows to work on but there's
months and weeks of preparation
and i quickly realized news is where
it's at news is you just really it's
it's quick it's turnaround it's new
every day um back in the day there was a
show called the big breakfast i really
wanted to work on never got to
never got there i ended up working for a
finance channel
and i was working sort of buried in the
back room booking satellite feeds
looking at uh cameras and making sure
they were okay recording things you know
very
all the kind of nuts and bolts that make
a television station work um
and again once i was there i realized
that you know directing looked like a
really fun thing to do so
so slowly i kind of advanced my career
and ended up learning those things and
coming in and figuring out how to do
that job and eventually getting a job as
a director
and then moving through various
different directing projects various
different organizations um until i found
myself here at sky news in the kind of
center of uh
you know uk breaking news um and 24-hour
news and
uh and running this whole team and and
being really proud of everything that we
do
and you know being sort of the head of
all these kind of various different
things all the studios and the cameras
and the directors and the crews that run
um and just being involved in it so it's
a fabulous environment to work in
so it sounds like it's been quite a long
journey for you what would your advice
be to to somebody who wants to be a
director where should they start where
should they be looking
um so if you want to be a director i
think the thing is you i always say it's
a lot of people you'll never
you'll you'll never jump in you'll never
fall into the dream job on day one ever
i mean i i
came into television i didn't even
really if i'm really honest i didn't
know what the director did i knew i
wanted to work in live news but
i'd only ever seen you know production
areas and
i ended up working in the back room
because that was where the job was
actually it gave me an incredibly good
grounding of what
what a television station does and i
would say that you know
the trick is really to to find your way
and find your way into this industry
take anything almost you know if there's
if there's an opportunity if there's
work experience if there's just intern
whatever it would be
um things like this just just looking
investigating
the industry and find your own way you
might think you want to be a director
and you might end up being working on
the production side
um i know people that have gone either
way
but whatever you do love what you do and
learn everything you can from what you
do and learn from the people around you
because the great thing about television
is
it's an incredibly collaborative
industry and i can't do my job without
knowing
the pressures that everyone else is
under the presence that you're under the
katarina all the people in that room
all the people in this newsroom um
you're learning all the time
and whilst you're learning you're also
learning what fires you up it's a
brilliant place to almost
forge your own career you can end up you
know have carving your own niches you
know i'm
i've done a lot of projects in my time
there are other directors that love
doing sport there are other directors
that would
um you know get more involved in the
audio side of it some people do just
single bespoke shows that happen once a
week some people do like we do 24 hours
a day there's
there's hundreds of thousands of
different jobs and you won't know what
they are until you get involved so just
so just keep your eyes open keep
learning and be nice to everyone it's a
small industry
um but enjoy what you do yeah and ben do
you think you need to have
a contact industry or is it
simply a case of you know having a bit
of luck in and hard work that hard work
does eventually pay off
yeah i mean listen it's it's not those
a lot of these things generally come
through contacts but those contacts can
be quite weak um it's good i think it's
always good to have a really big network
um my my kind of initial contact into
the industry was
when you know someone knows someone who
knows someone who knows someone and i
got a job that i didn't really expect to
get uh or i certainly got a
trainee position that i didn't expect to
get um
but this i one thing i would say it's an
industry that really rewards
it does really reward hard work i know
you a lot of people might say that but
like
if you're keen and good at what you do
uh this industry wants to keep those
people because
uh they they're the people that fire up
you know it's not it's not always an
easy job
but it's generally always a fun job um
so that the
anywhere you start uh if you're just i i
my first ever job i'll give you an idea
my first ever
job but barely paid anything i was i was
kind of making croissants for editors in
the in a soho production house
uh not making going and buying if i'm
honest um but uh but i kind of made it
my my principle to make sure that
everyone knew
i got the exact right order every time
and i made sure everyone knew you know i
only got the right coffee you never
thought the sugars that kind of thing
and they responded to that and i
learned a lot about it because they
liked me and they like you know they
enjoyed being with me and i
learned a lot about that kind of thing
and that kind of if you keep that kind
of idea that
you know everyone can teach you
something and and as long as you're nice
to people as long as you kind of want to
learn from people as long as you're keen
about what you're doing
you will eventually carve your way in
this industry so it's a brilliant
industry for just allowing that to
happen
great advice ben we'll leave you to it
thanks for your time well ben
has gotten now he's showing you about
the around the gallery i want to show
you
about the world of tv and the studio so
this is
studio six it's one of three studios
that we broadcast from uh
in london the other one is over in sky
central not too far from where i'm
saying now
we've got another studio over there
milbank in the westminster you can see
the news that's pretty impressive and
nice and shiny you've got a couple of
monitors here
and split screen so then if you can make
that out you've got split screen so you
can see what
um the other broadcasters are up to
you've got
here cameras one cameras two cameras
three
all of them have got autocue and people
like ben directors like ben
can keep on talking to me communicating
with me
let letting me know what stories we're
moving on to next they're monitored so
you can see the output and this guys
is one of my favorite parts of the
studio this
is the green area so you can see green i
can see green but when you're sat at
home
watching the telly it's something
completely different
it's pretty remarkable when you see it
our amazing graphics teams they come up
with graphics and animations
and we use this area for special
discussion uh special uh programs we had
one quite recently with jillian joseph
one of our presenters
uh which came after the um the killing
of george floyd in the black lives
matter
um protester manahan one of our other
presenters he did a program called after
the pandemic
which really looked at um what the world
would be like
um after covert 19 is finally over
whenever that will be up here you've got
what we like to call
the jib camera this is a really cool
piece of kit
so you have a camera operator and he can
basically
move that camera wherever he gets some
toll to
buy you've got it there yeah wherever he
gets told to by the director it can go
up and down left and right it's a really
really cool piece of kit so that's just
a little snippet
about what it's like to be in the studio
there tends to be
a floor manager who um makes sure that
everything is in working order
uh and it's uh it's a really exciting
place
to work now let's moving on from tv
we're going to talk about the world of
social media
hugely important now um in the world
that we're living in
and we're going to talk about video
journaling journalism this speaks to her
alex marshall hello alex good to see you
what can you tell us about your job what
do you do from day to day
hi kamal i am the assistant editor
for the digital video team at sky news
um so
it's a small but perfectly formed team
of five editors and and i i manage those
guys on a day-to-day basis
and we within the team we pitch we
produce we edit and we publish digital
video
and we as you say social media is our
you know our bread and butter so we do
publish our videos
on the sky news app and website but we
also publish
on youtube on snapchat uh instagram
including igtv
facebook twitter tick tock there's
probably more that i've forgotten but we
have a whole lot of platforms that we
deliver content to um
and i guess the types of video that we
do sort of fall into two
sections so there's there's making the
best of our tv content
as you guys have heard we've got a huge
tv operation that are you know
constantly making brilliant content
so we re-optimize that content but for
digital so that might mean
um adding subtitles adding captions
making the video shorter maybe vertical
for a phone
um so that's all about optimizing
existing content
um and then there's the stuff that the
team and myself will pitch
kind of from within the team itself
that's very digital specific
um and that can be anything you know
from explainers for youtube where they
play really really well
and also some of our own sort of
investigative journalism
as well why is it so important that we
are
on these platforms we have we have such
a presence on
these platforms like facebook snapchat
instagram
yeah i think i think the main point is
to to attract as as many different
types of people as possible so the
audiences are
so vastly different on each of those
platforms and tv as well so sky news as
a brand you know you know it is putting
up news to
30 from 13 year olds to sort of however
old people are
you know watching all those different
platforms so for example on snapchat 75
of the audience is actually under 24 so
you know that's a huge portion of
that of that platform and we can you
know give them news and give them
content that they actually want and
really engage them in in news
um in a way that they actually can
access and enjoy
um and also the the different platforms
themselves
lend themselves to different types of
video so for example youtube obviously
is brilliant for long
form uh videos so we can make content
that's sort of short and snappy and goes
on twitter and it's that moment video
that
huge explosion all the you know that
kind of viral video but we can
also produce video that's 10 minutes
long that's you know an investigative
piece into
um something that we did recently all
about why thailand's roads are so
dangerous for drivers so it just gives
us a huge variety of content
and audience as well and does it feel
like we've constantly got to reinvent
ourselves if you get something like
um take top for example it wasn't around
that long ago
yeah i mean tick tock we had to uh kind
of react to
uh we actually joined it during lockdown
which has been interesting um but yeah
we're absolutely we we try and innovate
we try and react really quickly to new
platforms and
and new types of video new styles of
video um
and you've got to imagine you know these
audiences are only getting bit bigger so
like
i think it's five billion videos are
watched on youtube every single day
um you know you can't underestimate how
huge these audiences are
um but what i would say is good video
will always
perform well or sort of you know this
you know very uh kind of
attention-grabbing video will always
perform well so for example recently the
beirut explosion
that was our biggest performing video
just because it was just such
shocking content you know so i don't
think you have to kind of be
sometimes too clever about it it's just
making the most of the content that's
out there
and do you have to be a trained
journalist in order to be a video
journalist
well i would say that um journalism
always helps we we absolutely hold
ourselves to the highest of editorial
standards on the team
um but i would say that um of the team
there are people in there that haven't
gone through this sort of more
traditional
journalism degree or masters in
journalism or what have you all
um they're actually trained um operators
so i've got guys on there who are
brilliant film filmmakers brilliant
editors brilliant
sound operators and sound designs and
also graphics as well so
i would say even if you don't
necessarily have a journalism degree
there are absolutely like
incredibly valuable skills that you can
get and also teach yourself because
there's so much resource on the internet
out there you can teach yourself to film
you can teach yourself to edit
and you can teach yourself how to make
graphics and those skills will make you
really really really valuable to
to a team like mine so yeah i would say
it's helpful but not necessary
what gets you up in the morning alex
coffee
so um i think you know every day is an
exciting day at sky news i think you'll
hear that from everyone here and every
day is different you know
it's always exciting always keeps you on
your toes and you're constantly having
to be creative so
that's what i enjoy most about my job
and what would you say the top tips are
to get your video shared
thousands of times well you've got a lot
of competition out there you know it's
really hard
but i would say i think the opening
three seconds
is your absolute key thing to make
people watch your video you know people
are just used to scrolling on their
phones
and you've got three seconds to capture
their attention so make that opening of
your video
the best it could possibly be um and
then throughout the rest of the video
keep it pacey
use music use quick captions use quick
cuts keep the
keep the speed up um and then i i would
like our videos to either answer a
question or provide context to something
so
make people want to watch it make them
want to answer a question and learn
something from it i think those are our
kind of top three things
great bits of advice alex we'll let you
get thanks for your time see ya
thank you guys we really really want
your questions so keep typing them using
the q
and a functions as they say we've got a
really great panel and they
want to hear your questions and they
want to answer your questions so
keep tap tap tap tapping away um now we
promised a little bit more broadcasting
we're going to take you to the world of
sky news radio
let's talk to anastasia bates who's in
their radio studio
hi anna good to see you um what can you
tell us about your job
hi kamal yeah it's great to be here so
um sky news radio provides
the news content to around 300
commercial
stations um so our job is to take the
news stories of the day
and write scripts in a way that is sort
of quite short quite snappy get to the
point
um can be easily understood just by
listening to them
but also can be quite easily read aloud
because ultimately that's how we're
relaying our information
um we also send full-length interviews
we also send our stations um
sort of live stream press conferences so
they can opt into them
um but there's also quite a lot of
variety so we um
script ourselves and record business
roundups so all the latest business news
and showbiz stories as well so lots
and lots of variety yeah so is write the
script for
radio different to write and say an
online piece
absolutely because with radio we're
our bulletins are only two minutes in
length so we've got a lot of information
to cram into not a very
long space of time and also we've not
got pictures we've not got
the the beauty of load of time to really
get into the nitty-gritties to explain
things um and again to show pictures and
video we we don't have that
but the beauty of radio in a completely
different way
is just how sort of impactful audio can
be on its own
so for example if you've got like a
massive protest
you can't see how many people are there
so we have to explain
tens of thousands of people have
gathered in a square and then we could
show um record and and play out some
audio of the sound effects of that
protest
so you get a sense you get a feel for
what it's like there you can
imagine it in your mind without actually
seeing it and
something that um alex touched on there
was the beirut explosion being being so
massive obviously what made
so much of that sort of gripping was
what it looked like
and we didn't have we weren't able to
show that so we had to sort of say
explain you know mushroom clouded smoke
we had to really describe what was
happening what you could see um so yeah
it is completely different but i think
radio's magic in a completely different
way so
it's a broadcast but anna one of the
things that people ask me is
whether you need to have a particular
kind of accent or a particular kind of
voice
in order to be a broadcaster in order to
go into radio
what would you say to them i'd say
absolutely not
there's no there's no right accent um
i'm from the northwest of england
um so i say grass instead of grass i say
bath instead of bath
um there are differences in our accents
and that's
that's what makes it great you know
we've got people on the team from
absolutely
all over with the most diverse range of
accents and i think
i think that is great because ultimately
like you want to
i think it's important for people to
hear the news read to them
by somebody that sounds like them so
it's important that we represent the
people that we are representing and i
think
a wide range of accents is fantastic
how did you get into radioana so i
started a small station in
chester um it was
really small the team was absolutely
tiny but in a way
it was great because i had so much
responsibility straight away
um so pretty much on my first day i was
writing scripts i was on air
um reading the bulletins i was reporting
i was looking after our social media
channels as well
nowhere near to the extent that you've
heard alex talk about but um
still it's it's a different side to the
job and because we were such a small
team we got
the chance to do everything and it's
where i sort of really learned
how radio works how local government
work how local communities
work and realize just how impactful
radio can be and
what how important radio is for these
for these communities
yeah so what would your top speed top
tips be for somebody that wants to get
into radio
um it would be to um
definitely listen to radio listen to how
it's
how it's how the news is relayed on on
radio and and
how scripts are written and that sort of
thing um
throw yourself out there try and do as
much as you can um
obviously local radio and the the sort
of dynamics of the radio industry is
changing as
so many other things are so just try and
sort of
work your way into it and just be as
open
and honest and enthusiastic as
you possibly can be because i think
ultimately that's
that's what sets you apart if you if
you're properly like driven
and enthusiastic i think that's that's a
thousand percent the way to go
what gets you up in the morning anna um
obviously my job i love my job
and i don't just have to say that i
really do
um and yeah again it's just so much
variety
every day is different you think you
know how your day is looking and then
something huge will happen
and it'll all completely completely
change
but yeah definitely my job
walking tell us about the stories that
you're covering and how you will
um treat them so um
today for example for example where um
what's leading our bulletins is the
sentencing of the
um christchurch attack in new zealand
last year
and the biggest ever sentence handed
down in that country so we're
we're treating it really sort of
seriously you know it was
it was a huge event at the time um
and we've had some some great sounds
from the prime minister
of new zealand um some of the survivors
of the
the attack reacting to that sentence um
so that's
that's our top story today um
quite a lot going on today i'm not gonna
lie it's been it's been a
busy busy day um but yeah
that's that's what's gonna lead our
bulletin in what time is it 13 minutes
time
13 minutes time and just just before you
go anna you did touch on it
many people will worry about whether
they have to go
straight to london after um they end
their training
what would you say to them because you
started the northwest of england you
don't necessarily have to go to london
you can go to different parts of the
country yeah
absolutely you absolutely don't need to
be
in london to do this job um there's
radio stations everywhere there's
journalists everywhere
you do not have to be in london to do
this job
massive believer of that um and yeah
just
just really get get to know the
communities that that you're
representing and
it's it's by doing that that i realized
how important and how impactful radio
can be
and that's not a london thing that is an
everywhere
thing so absolutely london obviously i'm
here now and i love it but it's
it's not everything and
uh we'll leave you to it you've got your
bulletin and what you're just over 10
minutes time
so really good to chat thanks very much
for your time we're going to stay
thank you guys and we're going to talk
about podcasting
our producers have joined us from the
newsroom hey sabha
hi thanks for having me
sure so i work with skye's radio
department and i'm currently doing
podcasts so i work on the sky news daily
podcast hosted by der mcmanahan
and it really is a sort of 30 minute
exploration
into the sort of story of the day the
story of the week
and my role is to source suitable guests
it's to structure uh how we tell the
story it's to you know help with the
scripting
it's to help with the recording of it so
running the desk in the studio
and the overall editing of the podcast
as well so there are quite a few
different components to
the work that i'm currently doing at the
moment why do you think podcasts have
become so popular
i think because the way that we can
consume news now
is so different to how we did sort of 10
to 15 years ago
you know most people tend to have
smartphones i say most because my uncle
who's 50 something he doesn't own a
smartphone and he refuses to but i feel
like generally most of us do
less of us are watching television we're
constantly on the go
and podcasts are portable so you can
listen
and consume your news anywhere you know
on the train on the way to work on the
way to school wherever you are
you are able to do that and that's the
beauty of it
how did you get into podcasting so
i work as a multimedia producer here at
sky and
my job sort of allows me to move around
the newsroom to the different department
so i started off working
with the breakfast team um sort of doing
six months
of overnight shifts and then my next
rotation after that was with the radio
team
um and i started off you know just
working on the sort of daily radio news
and then from there i moved to producing
my own podcast
which was a sort of good news
coronavirus one so you know
the nice moments coming out of the
pandemic you know
ordinary people doing extraordinary
things um
and from there i thought you know i've
developed these skills
doing this um and then i was uh put onto
the the daily podcast which is really
really growing um so that's how i
uh sort of fell into it um i i didn't
think you know
eight months ago when i started with the
radio team i would be doing podcast but
i'm so
glad that i am because it's really sort
of given me the opportunity to sort of
go
into a story in detail because with
daily news you don't have the
opportunity to do that as much
with television packages they're
typically about three minutes long
with our you know radio bulletins that
we do they're two minutes long but
anna's preparing for now um whereas with
a podcast you have up to around
30 minutes to really go in depth to look
at the nuances
things that often tend to get missed
with the other formats of news that we
have
and given that it worked in so many
different areas do you think that's
important to have a a good understanding
of how
podcasting works work on all these
multimedia platforms
oh 100 um and that's because news is not
we you can't look at news uh sort of in
a sort of tv vacuum
it's evolved so much since then you know
you have to look at the audio
you have to look at social media you
have to look at
digital online the way we consume news
is so
different as i mentioned earlier so you
have to have an understanding of how all
the different departments work
because you know if you want a story to
have sort of maximum
reach and to to target different
audiences
you need to be across the platforms so
for that
reason i'm very lucky that my job allows
me to go around the newsroom
because one you get to know different
people different ways of working but
also just the different styles so i'm
gonna you know once i finish
my sort of you know program which i
believe is two years long
i will have a holistic understanding of
how
everyone here operates um and i think
that puts me at
a an advantage really and what tips
would you give somebody that wants to
set up their own podcast
i would say it's really not that
difficult um
that's what i learned from doing a
podcast at home um during
you know sort of height of lockdown um
you just need a good microphone
you need to be good at scripting keep
your scripts
short um keep them as natural as you can
and just go for it absolutely go for it
um have sort of as the little less guest
that you have
the more time you have to explore
something in depth
um and it sounds like a task and a half
but believe me it's
it's very very doable um you know there
are so many different systems that you
can use
zoom is on that a lot of broadcasters
have been using we've been using that
quite a lot
as well to record things and it's free
um
so yeah there are loads of different
ways just do it how did you start off in
in the business so i
did a my undergraduate degree a few
years ago now in social anthropology
and that's basically the study of
cultures and the study of people
and i thought i'm quite nosy as a person
i like to know about different people
and how they operate
what sort of field lends itself to that
and
i think sort of journalism was the
natural fit for me so when i finished
um i went into sort of local television
so i was a producer and a tv presenter
for a community based channel called
british muslim tv i was there for sort
of two to three years
and then after that so during that stint
i decided i want to do something that's
a bit more
um meaningful for me there are so many
stories that i want to
tell and this platform isn't allowing me
to do that i decided i want to go to
news
so i did a masters at city university
which is a great way to sort of fast
track
into a career in a newsroom and then
from there i was able to do work
experience at sky
um which was great for a week so i had a
sort of feel for the newsroom
um and then i think maybe six seven
months after that there was a job going
i applied
and here i am here you are so what would
your top
tips be for somebody that wants to uh
get into the business
top tips okay so two tips that uh
pieces of advice that were given to me
that have resonated to this day i'm very
forgetful as a person but i remember
these two things
specifically the first one was given to
me by
uh bbc journalist and news reader
michelle hussein
and that was be so good wherever you go
that people think we need this person we
we
she's a they are a component within the
team and we can't let them go
work you know strive to work that hard
um
and that that sort of really helped me
in my career so far another one was
given to me
um by the the ceo of um
an organization that partnered with sky
mama youth program
um and that was don't ever give anyone
an excuse
to you know think you're not good enough
you know work hard
you have an idea put it forwards um be
on time
you know don't be late uh do everything
by the book
but even within that you know strive to
sort of be rebellious you know as sky
um you know have as one of their values
if you have an idea you know go for it
push for it and you know the industry
relies on on different voices and
different experiences
um and also last point i'd say if you
ever do experience you know imposter
syndrome
working in a newsroom which is very you
know it's a normal thing if you're a
woman if you're a
person belonging to an ethnic minority
know that you were there because you
worked hard and you deserve to be there
you are talented and you are there
because
you've done your bit you you've worked
hard they've seen something in you
so now sort of use that opportunity to
do the best that you can um and
just make the most of it guys you know
opportunities are there you have to be
hungry you have to be thirsty um
and you will be seen and recognized so
just
just keep going you will have you'll
have knockbacks i had so many knockbacks
when i was trying to sort of break into
mainstream media um
so many to the point i thought god is
this really something that i want to do
is this a sign
but um i kept pushing and here i am
so i'm very grateful there you are great
words of advice and positive wisdom
sabbah thank you very much for your time
we'll leave you today thanks for having
me see you soon
um right guys it's now time for your
questions um
let's introduce you to our panel um
those who have been working here as sky
news some for a number of years
some who have joined us more recently
firstly we have
peter lowe's the head of home news so
he's responsible for story coverage in
the united kingdom
in zama rashid is a sky news
correspondent he could get deployed on
any story
at a drop of a hat joe pike is our
fiscal correspondence he's based in
westminster aisha saheed is a sky news
apprentice and victoria seabrook
is a specialist producer welcome guys
good to see thank you for joining us
um the first question and only uh in one
sentence please how did you get into
news and peter asked the most senior
member
of the team here um can you kick off
please
hi gamal uh well i got into uh news when
the hot when the world was in black and
white i think
so it it really is literally four
decades ago that i
first went into news and in a way
because the the landscaping uh
broadcasting and news generally has
changed so much
how i got into it is in a way almost
irrelevant but i
i i managed to get a job at a news
agency
at the same time as i was studying and
you did it in a kind of block
release way which i don't think happens
so much now i used to go to cardiff for
three months and then go back to work
and it was a news agency actually is a
very good place to start
because it means that you are only
dealing with
uh big news stories uh you know from
quite an early age
that you can sell to to uh
you know to other outlets so i was kind
of writing for the financial times and
things like that at a very
at a very young age and it's good
training
how did you get into news uh i got into
news
firstly because i watched the news come
all and i
saw that actually there weren't many
people like me
on the news um and if there was ever
news about people like me
it was pretty much bad news um and i
remember sitting there
watching the nine o'clock news and could
only stay up past nine o'clock my dad
would only let us stay up past nine
o'clock
if we were to sit and watch the news and
i used to sit watch it and i was
engrossed by
news and i absolutely i love it i love
news
and so it was my goal as a little kid
then
uh sitting watching the news to make
sure that i got into it one day
and i i i've done it by nagging the hell
out of people i've sent
i've probably sent thousands of emails
to bosses
and people across the country to get
jobs in news and
and here i am in in one of the best jobs
in the world yeah can you tell um joe
how do you get into
this news uh mainly by making tea
run almost like work experience shifts
at a radio station called lbc made loads
of tea
so uh got to know everybody in the
organization it's a great way at the
bottom when you start just uh
do all those sort of runner jobs get to
know everyone work out the lay of the
land and work out what you're interested
in and maybe what you're not
um i sure at the sky news apprentice and
how do you get your foot in the door
um so when i was at school i enjoyed
writing
which led me to take part in the school
newspaper
and that carried on throughout uni so i
took part in student media
and set up my own radio show and after
leaving uni brought up with work
experience building my portfolio and
then
joined skye through this apprenticeship
scheme victoria what about you
i used to do something completely
different i used to work
in the music industry and then one day
had a bit of a an epiphany and a change
of heart
um so i did a masters at city in
investigative journalism
and i also started working a local
newspaper which was brilliant
uh well look our moderator natalie's
been looking at the questions that um
the guys have been
um sending us and i'm happy to say that
there are lots and lots of questions
that have come in so
that's if you could kick off please sure
um lots of people are asking whether it
would be better to go to university to
do an apprenticeship
or to study a degree such as media
production
okay peter as the head of home news um
what are your thoughts
i think that um if you want to be
a news journalist and that's what you've
set your sights on in the
in the way that um many you know in the
way that uh in india did and i did
many years ago i think you need to do
something that's connected
to journalism so i'm not i'm not against
people going into
media production but it is possible to
do a degree in media production and not
have advanced
very far in your understanding of
how we make news how we write news how
we report news on television
and and so on so i mean there are some
very very good bespoke
courses in this country to learn the art
of journalism
but i also i also think that there are
definitely other routes and what one of
the dangers
is that when you take all of when you
when you take
lots of people who've done three-year
degrees or
um postgraduate courses in journalism
is that you you miss out on on part of
society that maybe
actually hasn't been able to afford to
go to university or something like that
um but i i think people should just do
what they want to do
so i have definitely taken on people as
journalists who did a degree in
geography or politics or or something
like that
the key thing is to be interested in
what's going on in the world and that is
that is your biggest calling card really
okay that's peter and that's if we have
another question please
yeah um how has covered 19 affected us
in the office and working out in the
field
um i mean you've been out about covering
this story from
from day one really what would you say
um in the field look we've had to take
some serious extra precautions
um what's being out this has been the
biggest story
that journalists today would have worked
on uh
in their in their lifetimes um it is
certainly the biggest story i've ever
ever worked on
i've only been uh you know in journalism
for for the past four to five years
and um it's been
really bizarre because this is a story
where people
where sixty thousand plus people have
died in this country
um i've been going out to speaking to a
lot of the families who have lost loved
ones
and usually you'd be able to sit down in
their home and speak to them and
understand the pain and heartbreak that
that they're facing but
you know we've had to do interviews
outside from
outside people's houses looking at them
into their windows into their doors and
holding
long poles with microphones on the end
two meters away
um constantly hand sanitizing varying
face masks
where we need to and it has made
life very difficult we've done a lot of
zoom
virtual things like this the reason
we're doing a virtual session today is
because of
the kobe 19 pandemic and it's it's
changed the way we've reported
massively but we've adapted we've found
ways to do it and i think that's the
beauty of
of journalism and the beauty of tv and
in particular
you know broadcast is that we we've
found a way around it and whilst it's
been
tough and and a lot of changes
uh we've got there and and i think we've
produced some of the best
journalism we've ever produced um at sky
and probably
across this country as well yeah partly
practically part of sky news
that's if we have another question
please lots of people are wondering what
sort of a levels would be best to take
to get into a career in journalism
um joe you're based at in normal banker
what would you say
i said i i i i believe it's not that
important
what you say at a level you should you
should take something that you enjoy
something you're interested in something
you're passionate about
i think what is brilliant about most
news organizations is that
people aren't all the same they don't
have the same background they don't have
the same
career they haven't followed the same
steps up the ladder to get where they
are
and that um diversity that range of
views that range of experiences is key
so i think um any a level is
is good if it's languages if it's
science there are lots of areas i'd say
maybe science is one of them where
a lot of media organizations probably
don't have enough
uh experienced knowledgeable qualified
people and covert 19 of course is a
story where
all of us have had to get our minds
around
things like that so i think there's no
there's no right path
it's more about um looking at where
you're interested in
and then working really hard to get into
a news organization
yeah good advice that's another question
please
yeah uh what's the hardest news story
you've had to cover was it difficult in
terms of emotional difficulty or
logistical difficulty
that's a good question victoria what
about you
there's two things that spring to mind
one of them isn't that
uh original but when coronavirus first
hit that was really difficult
back in um in february and march time i
was
one of the specialist producers working
specifically on science
so we were just flat out trying to get
our heads around what was going on
all around the world what is this virus
i think
much like the rest of the world and
scientists around the world and it was
moving
so quickly and there was so little that
we understood
at the time that was quite difficult and
the other example is
i've just been covering uh belarus for
the last two weeks
where there's um potentially a um
well there's a there's huge protests
there against the regime
and that story also just moved so
quickly that you have to be
on top of everything all of the time so
from as soon as you wake up checking
what's happened overnight
right until before you go to bed making
sure that there's nothing that you've
missed but
it was really exciting because uh it
feels like you're
you're working on a really significant
historical moment
natalie another question please
what skills would you say are most
important to develop for a successful
career in journalism
well i i should ask you a head of home
use that i'm sure he's got some uh
wonderful ideas
well i i think if you are contemplating
it
i mean i i have met people in the past
who've said
that uh they're quite interested in this
and they're quite interested in that but
they also thought about maybe
journalism i don't think you can think
about maybe journalism i think you've
got to be
interested enough in the news uh that
you're det
that you that you're actually determined
to be a journalist
if you're a young person who doesn't
read
or listen or watch news then maybe
you don't have the right amount of
curiosity to pursue a career in it
but driven people like you know we heard
from saber earlier and we heard
from indy about how he was you know
trying to stay up to watch the news as a
as a as quite a young boy that
so that's the first thing you need uh is
is to have that genuine
interest and then in terms of the skills
that you require
um it's it's pretty important to be able
to write well
i would say in any kind of journalism in
in radio
television or obviously the written word
um and but i think the other thing is to
be creative to have creative ideas
about ways in which visual storytelling
uh can be done
on television or on on social media
or any of our on any of our other
platforms
so it's it's interesting the subject
good writing skills good communication
skills if you're ever going to be a
reporter on television
you've got to be able to articulate
fluently
and and clearly to the audience
otherwise they won't understand what
you're saying
and yes creative ideas
lisa thank you natalie next question
please is confidence a key part of the
job
aisha what do you think
um i think so i feel like in the
newsroom for me at the start imposter
syndrome can feel quite overwhelming but
having that confidence in yourself that
actually
with the apprenticeship the training
that i received beforehand that puts me
in a good place
um with a good understanding of how
things work
and also having the confidence to ask
questions as well if you're not sure
no one expects me to know how everything
works um especially as this is my kind
of first stint in journalism
to having the confidence to be curious
and ask help if you need it
yeah and and i should the term imposter
syndrome has popped up a couple of times
uh during this virtual talk troll how
would you describe it what is it
um i guess for me kind of walking in
actually everyone here has so much
experience so much is happening
um and just feeling that maybe you don't
have as much experience
um yourself but it's important to look
at what you have done
and so for myself at university i did a
bunch of things with
paper with radio kind of taking world
issues applying them to students
and actually from your previous
experiences even if they aren't at
national places national papers
you have still demonstrated skills even
if it's on a smaller scale
okay next question please natalie
is it difficult not to be biased when
writing and compiling news stories of
course everyone has their personal
opinions so how do you block those out
when writing a news story for a news
channel
such as skye in easy i'm not asking you
that one
um look you have to be fair
as possible you have to give everyone uh
their view
and be as balanced as possible it's our
job as
journalists to tell the story when i go
out and i'm witnessing a scene
it's it's down to me to tell what's
happening to give context
to the story and then to hear views from
different people and to give
a balanced argument as well so that i
think that's one of the biggest things
in the in the back of your mind is to
remember to
stay balanced to um to make sure that
everyone's voices
are heard and sometimes it can be very
difficult if you're out on a protest
for example and you're only with with
one side of the protest and
and they are um you know they're
protesting about whatever
it is they're protesting about then
you're hopefully
relying on a colleague or someone else
delivering some other coverage to offer
some balance or you yourself to offer
some balance by
um by asking them questions which will
challenge them
basically and and that's that's one of
the most important things as well is
that
when you know someone's got very kind of
harsh or maybe very radical views is
that you as a journalist
are there as well for the other person
and can challenge whoever it is you're
speaking to
so i think having that balance and
making sure that things
aren't biased and also not letting your
own emotion
get involved too much as well um
is is incredibly important and at times
can be very difficult but
um again if you're if you're focused on
making sure that everything's fair
and you just want to tell the story then
you could get through that
joe can we explore this question a
little bit further with you you're a
political correspondent
often hate hearing that we live in a
very polarized world and politics can be
very polarized
it can be but i think you've just got to
tell
both sides of the story and you've got
to try and understand the positions of
the different in my case political
uh parties i think one thing that does
help with that
is that naturally in the job you do
spend your time
up close uh with people so if you think
you have a particularly positive or
negative view
towards a particular party or a
particular politician
it is it can be sort of um positive and
refreshing to see everyone up close and
realize that
ultimately i think everybody is just
trying to
get through try and do their uh jobs
reasonably well of course some of them
maybe not be maybe sort of failing at
that but i do i i just think you've got
to tell both sides of the story you've
got to realize that it's not our job
to have an opinion it's not our job to
be a player in any of this
we are merely communicating it and
trying to make sense of it in politics
of course there
is can be a lot of sort of spin people
trying to
explain what they've done in a
particularly particularly positive way
and we've got to drill down into that
but i think you've always got to tell
both
sides of the story because one that's
what
we owe to our viewers and the readers of
our
people who consume our news but also i
think once you go
down the any other route you you can get
yourself in trouble it takes a long time
to build up trust as sky news has done
over decades
it you can very quickly lose that trust
that is
clearly dangerous sure and what do you
think peter i mean how do we remain
fair and impartial and leave our own
views
to one side uh kamal i think
one thing i agree with what uh what joe
and indy have said about having to tell
both sides of the story
i think one thing that's just important
for people to know if they don't
is that there is a very big difference
between the world of broadcast and the
world of newspapers on this
so the the daily mirror can put on their
front page
uh gavin williams should be sacked they
could you know write a writer
an opinion column saying that um we
can't and shouldn't do anything like
that because broadcasting in this
country is actually regulated
uh by act of parliament actually to be
fair and impartial and so
all of the journalists here spend mo a
lot of their time
ensuring that there is proper balance
and fairness about the coverage that we
do
and it's it's even more important now
than it used to be
because if you look at the cacophony of
stuff on social media
and the the kind of views that are
expressed on social media and
and and people putting out their own
sometimes very
biased or polarized views about things
it's really important
that there are news organizations like
ours
that are telling the story straight and
making sure that people have
both the facts and both sides of the
argument
peter thank you natalie another question
please yeah is that career and
journalism inaccessible for people who
aren't from near london
uh victoria um ask you that question
what do you think
no i don't think that that's true um as
peter and indy have already described
the most important thing
is that you're interested in news you're
interested in the world
why things are the way they are you want
to you want to
ask anyone you can anything you can um
there is a there is a concentration of
of media in london
and a concentration of decision makers
and influential
people and organizations but it's
absolutely possible
and working for local outlets so local
newspapers or regional tv channels or
radio stations
can be a really good way in because you
working in a smaller place you get
exposure to lots more things
and also you can be working on all
different kinds of stories straight away
and so it's a great place to learn
how the world works if you're doing one
day you're doing a story about
your local hospital which has lost some
funding and the next day you're doing
something about the local council it's a
really good way to just
get your head around how how lots of
things work yeah i started off in
regional news myself and it's a great
place to learn your trade um
india you're not from london so what is
your take on this
yeah i'm from the northwest of england
from warrington and i'm currently
actually sat
in manchester because i'm covering the
the north of england
uh for a while whilst one of our
correspondents is away
in in america um and i
kind of first started off uh locally
at local radio stations writing
bulletins
going out reporting doing little voice
notes and sending them back which would
go out
on commercial radio stations and then
and then i managed to get a job at
bbc local radio and just like victoria
said working at local level and like you
said kamal
it was the best grounding i found
because
you you built foundations of what it was
to be a journalist and to build as very
core skills um and then you could just
add
layers on top of that you know you bring
in your own stories and then you can
develop contacts with people as well
and i found you know working in the
northwest of england
was a great place because there's so
much news here
you know there's so many sort there's so
many stories to kind of get into
and develop and i was always kind of
very against the idea of going
down to london i was like well there's
so much up here you know the bbc have
got a great
uh a great setup here as well
um you know sky sky have got three uh
almost four correspondents up here big
number of camera crews as well and
there's lots of news organizations to
work up for here
and then when i was offered the
opportunity to to join sky and move down
to london
i thought okay well this is a big
decision because i've always said no i
don't want to go to london but i did
and it has it has been great but the
opportunity is back up here now and you
know
soon hopefully i'll be back up here in a
more kind of permanent
uh position to to be a north of england
correspondent and to
to deliver news in essentially the patch
which is which is where i'm from so i
can tell stories
hopefully and a bit better yeah in your
home um
that's another question please what sort
of entry level jobs or apprenticeships
are available in sky news
oh i sure i think that one's definitely
for you
yeah so with the apprenticeships they've
got the apprenticeship scheme
for the production route and the
reporter route and so the reporter one
is what i'm currently doing
um but both are great because they're
flexible enough to let you um
see around the newsroom spend time with
different teams
and doing different tasks and you still
learn um
how the whole place works but also at
the start of both of them you get
six months of training which kind of
trains you up in media law
um kind of how to write in a more
journalistic way
how government structures work you get
all that foundation and knowledge
there at the beginning too yeah and also
how much gym support how much
development is there that have you been
receiving
oh the support is great so with the
course we've got a mentor there we've
got mentor at sky
and everyone every team i've been with
has been so friendly and everyone is
happy to help
and so it's been a really welcoming and
friendly environment to kind of start
off with
it's great to hear um nasty no we have
another question please
do you have a lot of creative freedom
when deciding on news stories
oh victoria's the specialist producer i
think that one's gonna be for you
uh yes that's one of the things i love
about my job is that we get lots of
freedom to come up with ideas for
stories so
i'm a producer which means can mean lots
of different things but
what i do is a mixture of journalism and
tv production
so coming up with story ideas but also
working out how you how you tell those
on television how that translates
into translates visually
and i'm one of the specialist producers
here so we have some
producers which work specifically on
certain topics
and in those jobs particularly you get a
lot of freedom to come up with
with ideas and you still have to pitch
them in and
you have to sell them to your editors
and your bosses and they scrutinize them
which sometimes can be painful but is a
really helpful experience because they
make you
um they make it helps make sure that
you've been really thorough and working
out is this a good story
am i going to tell it in the right way
does it stack up
has something like this been being done
before but
certainly that is one of the things i
like most about the job that i do at the
moment
is the is the freedom um
okay and that's another question please
how would you usually get in contact
with people for interviews
oh that's uh that's a correspondent
question there if i ever i've heard of
one
of joe how'd
you go through uh press officers people
whose
full-time job is to interact with the
media
whether it be broadcast or papers or
whoever
sometimes if you're looking for an
eyewitness or someone who's involved in
a story you might
use social media you could use facebook
i think it's
most common that we perhaps use twitter
if someone is on twitter you maybe
direct message them dm them but of
course um
sometimes when you need to get to a key
person who has
some great insight or who's been at the
center of the story you do need to
go and find them physically and that
might be going to their workplace
standing outside
uh or it might be knocking on their uh
door
lots of um rules about how you do that
carefully and properly and
and fairly but there are lots of
different
ways i suppose the one thing that is
certainly important in 24 hours the way
we work is that
if you want to talk to somebody you need
to often talk to them quite quickly
so however whichever technique you're
using we're trying to move quite fast so
we get to somebody and talk to them get
their story before
our rivals but also because the news
changes so fast
uh there's often uh you know we're often
if you're in the news we're not
interested in what you're saying in a
week's time you want you today or
uh tomorrow so different ways to do it
but you gotta do it quickly yeah how do
you do it lindsay because you know
you're always looking to
build on your contacts and assignment
yeah i think i've got to echo a bit what
joe said there in terms of getting in
touch with people on social media
it's such a big help nowadays when you
are trying to find people when you when
you want to get in touch with people i
think
if if i use the the pandemic as as um
um i've spent a lot of a lot of the
pandemic speaking to
to families of those who who've lost
loved ones
uh and a lot of the time you'll see
names kind of pop
up through social media someone posting
saying that
they've sadly lost their their mother
their auntie their uncle their brother
um and it's it's one of the most
hardest jobs to to reach out to people
who have lost loved ones um but
i think there's a way of doing it and if
you if you're genuine if you're very
um approachable and it goes back to what
peter said about having communication
skills
um you know then then that can work but
it can be so so difficult
so using social media is is a great tool
um
i think you know building contacts when
you're just kind of out and about
reporting as well sometimes people will
come up to you and
and just talk to you or often i found as
well through the pandemic again
is when i covered the story around how
the coronavirus was disproportionately
affecting black asian and minority
ethnic people
i found that when i was covering that
story there were people
in senior positions whether it was in
the government or or whether it was
medics in the country
were getting in touch with me because
they trusted my storytelling they
trusted the way
that i was reporting and so then they
were offering me
insights as well which i had which i'd
never have got if
i was just kind of chatting to someone
every day on the street and so that was
really important i think once you've
done something which people kind of see
and notice
then people trust you and will come to
you with stories and other contexts to
put you in touch
with so so pizza building relationships
is so important for our line of work
as the head of news that is something
that you encourage
i think we might have just lost the
sound off uh
with peter um kamal i'm back now it was
a it was uh there was another connection
or something but
i seem to be here now yeah i was just um
picking up on um
indizi's last remarks um building
relationships is so
important for the line of work that we
do so it's ahead of him
it's something that you encourage um
yes i mean all of our specialist
journalists
uh have their own sets of contacts
whether that's in the the world of
science or economy or business
or health or any of the any of the other
areas in which we have specialist
journalists
and all of our news reporters
are in a more general sense either on
the london router or people who work
around the country one of the ways in
which they
get news is by developing contacts so
that they know
so that they know what's going on i mean
i i also think news divides
very roughly into three three different
sort of segments of a pie chart
um one part of news is unexpected what i
call
unexpected happenings so there's a train
crash or there's a flood
or a cabinet minister resigns those are
things that everybody
knows at the same time and we can all go
and cover it
and then there are other things like
known known happenings so we know don't
we that next week
schools will be will be going back in
many areas of
of england and wales and we will want to
cover that story when it happens we'll
want to know
whether or not it it works from a social
distancing point of view whether
teachers are able to teach in the way
that they want to whether parents are
concerned
and so we do what we call you know we
set up that story
by getting in touch with contacts and
asking if we can be
in in a school and asking if we can talk
to parents and that's
that's another area where having
contacts is uh
is important but probably the most
important part of it is that
the third part of my pie chart which is
original and exclusive journalism
and these are stories that we have
decided to do
because we found out about them or
because we wanted to investigate
something or whatever it may be
and that's where having the contacts and
the people with the insights uh
is the most important to any journalist
peter thank you
natalie another question please how do
you overcome stress for the breaking
news story
things are developing all the time how
do you overcome the constantly changing
nature of a story
uh joe can i ask you that being pizza
mentioned a big politician resigning for
example i mean
how do you manage that scenario well i
suppose i'm still quite new to it at sky
sky of course there is probably more
pressure chris 24 hours and i've only
been at sky for maybe seven or eight
months
um but i suppose you you need to be calm
any role whether you're on screen off
screen whether you're in uh you know
working on
our digital platforms there is pressure
because uh time is of the essence things
need to happen they need to happen
quite fast and i suppose it's one about
building up confidence in your own
abilities but also
sort of the basic stuff about taking a t
a deep breath taking
taking your time you need to uh you need
to
develop skills about you know to be good
at good under pressure
and you need to get details right so
much about
um news and especially politics is about
detail
and understanding exactly what a new
story means so you've got to be able to
develop those skills i don't think i
don't think though that's something
you you would you know necessarily
develop
growing up so i think it does take time
um
but uh and i'm you know i also as i said
before you know i'm still pretty
new to it so you know i'm developing the
skills myself and
hope under pressure how do you manage it
victoria because
you know you're always working too tight
deadlines and you're going through
meetings and getting things um getting
getting things sorted with
correspondence and senior elements of
the team well i think this is probably
true of a lot of people but i
think i do my best work sometimes when i
am under pressure
there's nothing like a bit of pressure
to focus your mind which
probably some of you listening find when
you're revising for your exams that the
closer they get
suddenly the more you can concentrate
and that's true at work as well so it's
actually
sometimes it's quite useful the um the
pressure and the speed of things just
makes you amazingly
efficient um and also
the good thing about working somewhere
like sky news it's really big
and so all of all of your colleagues
have amazing contacts and that's one
thing i love about
our workplace is that everyone's very
collegiate they're very friendly and
helpful and so
i might be working on a story that isn't
particularly political but maybe overlap
somehow and i might contact joe
and if he's not working on that story
himself say i really need to get in
touch with this person
can you help me or have you covered this
story before
what should i bear in mind and that's
one of the great things about working
somewhere big like this
okay that's another question please
we've got lots of questions coming in
this is good news guys what do you
suggest to somebody who's starting out
and looking to build a career
in broadcasting they need to gain
experience but
coronavirus has limited many physical
work experience and internship
opportunities
peter would you go to answer that well
in a way i don't i i don't know how to
answer the question on
uh on the problem of um created by
coronavirus because it
it's uh incontrovertible that it's made
life
a lot harder for for people no question
about it um
in terms of what was the original
question is it
um what was that that and that's the
news
of the question uh yes i can
indeed um looking at
uh somebody who's looking to get into
the industry but at the moment because
of coronavirus that's been
impacted because the opportunities to do
apprenticeships
and internships have been limited yes
yeah so i think i i think that um it
perhaps goes back a little bit to
something i
i said already which is about
maintaining your your
interest
oh that piece of sound is it just
dropped once again um natalie if he's
still there
listen we have another question yeah how
do stories get assigned
do you have to find your own topics or
does someone hire up give them to you
try to analyze the news i mean rather
than simply watch it
watch it read it and then ask yourself
why did they do that
why was that the why was that story much
more important than the other story
uh maybe the person who put the bullet
in together has has not got it right
maybe you
you'd be able to do it better yourself
so i think main
you know maintaining that interest is
very important
but i don't i can't really answer the
question about how do you get an
internship
um when uh when it's blocked by
coronavirus i would only say that
you know we we have just taken on
another
new apprentice who i think is if you
like the the
the the year following um
aisha who's uh been talking on this um
on this call
um and she's still joining but the good
thing is that for the i think for the
first
uh
okay piece of sound has just dropped out
again i actually if i could just pick up
with you i mean what advice would you
give to somebody who was looking to
start an apprenticeship at somewhere
like sky news
um because of the limited opportunities
i'd say don't panic if there aren't as
many opportunities available at the
minute there always will be down the
line later
um but keep up your practice as well um
i've got quite a few friends who have
started
blogging or started their own podcast
during the lockdown
and there's plenty to talk about at the
minute as well so keep going with your
own personal ventures too
and because that will really be
beneficial when things kind of
kick up again and having that to show
that actually you have been productive
during this period
and keeping that up yeah they say well
um
okay natalie could have that question
again please
uh yep is it better to go into a
specific type of journalism such as
politics journalism or sports journalism
or go into journalism where you
can report on a variety of different
topics victoria
that's quite a difficult question i'm
not sure if there's
a right answer to that um it can be
really useful to start out
as a generalist because you get to learn
how
how all different parts of the world
work and what's going on and you can be
very
flexible having said that
it's great to have an area where you're
where you are the go-to person
for something you if if a story happens
that's related to what you're interested
in or what your expertise is you're the
person
um that everyone turns to and says tell
us what the story is
um and i don't think that you have to
decide that
when you're starting out i think that
that can reveal itself as
as you progress i think some people
um perhaps set out specifically to be a
political journalist for example but i
think
it's okay if you don't know that at the
moment and
i didn't follow quite the traditional
path where
i knew that i wanted to be a journalist
since i was born
i did some other things first and
although that has made it a little bit
harder
more when i did decide to get into
journalism actually that
background um that background in other
industries
has been really helpful for so for a
while i was covering
arts and entertainment and so having
worked in music for a couple of years in
london
that ended up being really useful but
now i'm i'm moving around so i did
a year in arts um about a year in
science and now i work on foreign news
so
you can um you can shift and change
about as well
yeah what are your thoughts of that
because she said you haven't always been
a political correspondent have you
no and i think it is quite difficult in
any
organization especially when you're
starting out as a journalist to be too
specific i think you need um
as victoria said to generally be across
a lot of news i certainly started out
answering phones booking guests on a
radio station
pressing buttons in in the studio uh
you know escorting guests in and out
it's sort of quite um
quite sort of general tasks and doing a
bit of entertainment we had to be across
the sport as well
i was always interested in politics so
something i sort of kept my
uh eye on but um i
worked in scotland covering politics
then uh in manchester and then in
newcastle and then in leeds covering
yorkshire so um
for me the politics was probably more
important than the city and the location
so i
had to travel around quite a bit before
eventually reaching
um london and my uh current job so i
think
if you start out generally if you have
you if you're really into
football or you're really into um
entertainment or science
keep your eye on it and then when you're
in an organization
then maybe you can push to be a bit more
involved or to shadow somebody or to
to show and prove yourself in a
particular area i think it's very
difficult when you're starting out
to be too specific yeah things better so
we've all done our fair share of
traveling haven't already uh natalie
another question please
how do stories get assigned do you have
to find your own topics or does someone
hire up give them to you
[Music]
well for the person that is higher up
how do stories get
assigned lisa well
uh i think that in terms of
there's quite a it's quite a sort of
tapestry of how people get assigned to
stories
so
i think peter's just dropped out uh
once again okay he wants to pick up on
that in indy
um how do stories get assigned to you uh
so this this this you can have
completely different days you can have
really wacky days when you're on um the
correspondence rotor uh which i am um
so you can call in one morning and they
could be an on the day news story
uh that they have decided in the morning
meeting the senior managers the output
editors
uh have all decided that okay this is a
story we would really like to tackle
today
and they'll have a discussion say right
well inzy is available today so we can
get him to get out and and cover that
story
for us so that's one way it can be
assigned the senior news editor will
then tell you
uh that right that is your task today
crack on here's a producer that will
work with you
and get the story in for seven o'clock
and make sure you get your
your mobile online copy in as well
so that's one way then they can be um
kind of long-term planning stuff so you
may have a story idea
yourself uh something that you've worked
up over
some time in your own time in some
office time that you've had and you
pitch it to
the planning producers the senior
planning producers and then they can
fill in days where you can go out do a
bit of filming
might take two or three days to do a bit
of filming and then you edit your piece
together
and then there can be a day where that
that piece can go
on the news it can go on the tv it can
go online
and so that's another way so you can sky
is brilliant because over the past
18 uh to 20 months i've been here
sky have really given me an incredible
opportunity to explore stories
which i think are are interesting which
i also think
that people find interesting and that it
will get the clicks online and it will
get people watching it on social media
or on youtube
and i think that's incredibly important
because each individual has their own
ideas of what's a good story and what
people are interested in
and what people would like so when
you've got all these different ideas
coming in
you're covering a big ground and i like
to
i like to give my own stories and and
bring original journalism to the table
and i think
for a corporation like sky and a
newsroom like sky news i think that's so
important because it means that you're
getting into all those corners that
many people and many different news
organizations may not
yeah i think we've got you again are
there other times when
a correspondence will be assigned a
story and then they will come back
to you to say no i don't think we should
be covering that we absolutely need to
be covering
this story is there ever is every time
when that happens
occasionally yes and i'm sorry about
earlier i've moved positions now in the
hope that it's uh it'll be better jamal
but um yes that does occasionally happen
uh at we're interested in something in
the newsroom
and we send somebody to cover it and
when they get there they
they ring in and say well actually it
isn't really quite like we imagined
um it may be is actually a better story
or it may be that
actually the story doesn't in our
terminology
stack up properly as it had been
envisaged
so my feeling in those situations is
always to
trust the people you know trust your the
ground
the person who is uh the person who's
there on the scene of a story
uh is clearly going to know more about
it than we do in our
ivory tower back in the newsroom yeah
eyewitness reporting please
do you need to look a certain type of
way to be on the telly
who should i ask that joe do you need to
look a certain way to the other telly
no uh absolutely um
not i think what is um brilliant about
what sky's been doing over the
uh past few years is that uh we're
making sure that
there is absolutely um a vast range of
people
not just um from uh different
ethnicities but different backgrounds
people who had university who hadn't
been
university
and working for us and i think um for a
broad
uh you know broad broad um you know
outside the sort of south and southeast
of england which of course a lot of
the media is focused in i think
you know our our business is far more
than tv i think on tv you do need to be
um smart you do need to um
people need to trust and listen to you
so some of that is about
um taking care of your appearance and
being smart but i don't think you need
to look
in any a different way and in fact it is
incredibly important that we have people
who look completely different on our tv
screens because then they can help
tell stories in different ways yeah well
tonight can i just say we can't always
be as handsome as you
and joe but obviously obviously
looking smart is crucial um i mean
wha what are your thoughts on that nz
you know you're looking at people who
are on tv in this panel myself joe
and yourself we're all very different
yeah look um i'm from a south asian
background
um i've got a beard um throughout the
pandemic i had
massive hair like we all did because we
couldn't
get it cut um and i i think
i think there is an element that that
you have to look presentable you have to
look
approachable as well um you know and and
i think when you're out and about
covering stories
um i'm talking about dress scents here
first you know if you're out
on the beach you know you don't want to
be wearing a suit uh
one because you're going to be
absolutely boiling and and two because
it just looks weird a man
in a suit on the beach um or if you're
outside number 10 as
as joe is um quite frequently you know
he always looks very smart in a nice tie
in it and a suit
outside the prime minister's house and i
think that's so important but in terms
of
in terms of me i you know i'm a i'm a
south asian
british pakistani um and i
like i said growing up i never saw many
people like me
on the tv and it doesn't really matter
what you look like as long as you are
a good journalist hopefully i am
um and and you are interested in the
news and and
and you want to deliver um good
strong stories then that's the most
important thing doesn't really matter
what you look like whatsoever
one thing i would say though is that if
you ever do work at sky and you
and you start wearing a coat make sure
that it's buttoned up properly because
peter lo will come up to you
and tell you that uh it needs to be
buttoned up properly
and to straighten your tie as well um
natalie another question please
what skills do you think are the most
essential for a modern journalist
that's a good question um victoria could
ask you that please
i would say definitely communication
um you know whether you're telling a
story whether you're
talking to someone whether you're trying
to persuade someone to talk to you
the ability to find people so we talked
earlier about how do you find people for
for um when you're working on a story
and i think the answer is
you try every avenue you possibly can so
whether that's social media their
professional work
profile their old university email
address because
time is of the essence um
and i also just wanted to quickly answer
a question that came up earlier about
how do you get work experience
when when it's during lockdown or
partial lockdown
and i would say don't be afraid to reach
out to people
find journalists on social media contact
them
ask them if you can have a virtual
coffee um
a zoom chat something like that because
we've all been there we all had to start
out and you have
everyone has to work hard to get get get
into journalism
and it is a very competitive industry
but
despite that when you're not directly
competing with someone people are
amazingly helpful
and collegiate and that's something that
really pleasantly surprised me when i
was starting out was
how willing people were to help me give
me advice give me some time
so if there's anyone who's job that you
want or you think you might like
one day contact them and ask them for a
chat and we are very busy so
you might have to be a bit patient if we
take a while to get back to you but
don't be afraid to contact people and
you never know you might cross paths
with them
again a few years down the line yeah
it's so important that you say that
because you know it wasn't so long ago
that we're
all starting up in the industry and you
know you're kind of itching
a bit nervous about your contacts and
you see their profile
on linkedin or whatever you like should
i drop them an email
there's no harm is there dropping
somebody a note to say look you have a
chat
for coffee they can either say one or
two things yes or no
there's no harm in trying joe i saw you
nodding your head there
well just briefly something that uh the
um that
came together i remembered i was briefly
uh working in manchester for itv granada
and who was the work experience one day
but inzy here
and i think he on that day gave a really
i mean i was
new um i was covering politics for them
and he was a really good example about
when you're out
when you're doing work experience make
an impression because
it was a day where there was some story
about um ukip a sort of
right-wing pro-brexit party and we
needed someone to go out and do an
interview with a politician
and we were in manchester and this was
in liverpool and i couldn't go out for
some reason we didn't have many
resources
and and what is quite rare is we sent
the work experience person out to
uh interview the politician and that was
indie and
um itzy came back with this uh
interview with so many newslines so many
new interesting clips and comments from
this politician
and i was thinking what like he has done
this interview
probably better than a lot of the
journalists used to be doing myself
exactly i was thinking like who is he
who is a god
but i also i mean maybe didn't mention
this to him but i said to the boss that
i was like
this guy is really really good he's come
back with this amazing interview
where this politician has been
encouraged carefully to say
some pretty um interesting things
and that was just him on a few days of
work experience so you can make an
impact and he certainly did
and it does underline how often is about
being at the right place at the right
time
um natalie another question please yeah
lots of people are wondering if there
are any courses that you can recommend
short or long term that people can study
to give them a head start in the
journalism
career peter can i ask you that because
there are a number of courses um
out there we also spoke earlier on about
you know their undergraduate courses
their postgraduate diplomas as
nctj courses i mean what would your
advice be what would your recommendation
be
yeah i mean actually i'm not the most
i'm not the best person to ask about the
differences between
lots of different colleges um because
uh that could have changed since it i
was sort of really close to that
but um but there are there are three or
four different ways there's
they're definitely courses that you can
do which don't involve a three-year
degree or a one-year postgraduate
which are run by the nctj the national
council for training of journalists
and they will if you contact them they
will have a whole host of information
about things that you can do
i know that some of those courses are
also done in conjunction with the
with the press association which um
which i think also has its own
training scheme but i'd have to check
the facts on that
in terms of um courses at universities
i think that my advice
would be that it it it's not necessarily
it's not necessarily the case that you
have to do a three-year broadcast
journalism degree
because although they're mostly very
good
uh places like uh nottingham trent and
and others
um the one thing it doesn't do is
actually
it teaches you the rudiment the you know
the
how to run a newsroom how to be a
reporter how to write and all the rest
of it
but actually doing a degree in
philosophy or history or politics
in some ways is just as good but then
you
but then you have to make a decision
about whether you do a postgraduate
course in the actual
nitty gritty of of journalism we we've
had a quite a long association
in the past with um city in london uh i
guess that's partly due to proximity but
it's also to do with the fact that it
it's always turned out very very good
students um
but i think we we need to have a much
you know well we do have a much uh wider
view
than that and and try to take people
from from all over the country
yeah yeah yeah i mean i i myself did my
postgraduate degree
um at city university it's a broadcast
journalism
it was accredited by the bjtc so they're
called
journalism uh training council um there
are also lots of bursary schemes um
available so it is something that i'd
really recommend um you guys all
have a look at there are out there you
just gotta go and hunt them down
find them and apply for them because
they're a really good way of getting
through the door and natalie another
question please
yeah there's such a huge and diverse
team within the newsroom how do you
manage to keep everybody motivated and
happy especially during a difficult
story
um aisha how are you kept motivated
and happy what have you learned in your
time at sky
um so that's a hard question because as
soon as i started here lockdown kind of
um
kicked off and i had self-isolate so i
was at home for about
um five months but i guess that's a good
example of how i kept motivated during
lockdown
and i think it was a project that i was
working on so um
it was um we had about six people in
leeds all living on the same road
making diaries for us um and it was
kind of we started with complete
strangers and it's that motivation to
get them to open us up to us and to
really chart and document their true
experiences of lockdown
and as the project went on and on um i
developed more skills kind of doing just
that kind of there were legal challenges
that came up
how do you keep that many people
interested and filming for you for that
amount of time and
and yes that motivation to get them to
open up
and provide their true experiences and
was something that really
helped me keep going over lockdown
period victoria what about you
how have you remained motivated because
all of us have felt a pinch of blood now
yeah it's um it's difficult and it's
different
but i think it's just useful to remember
that it's difficult and different for
everyone
and the good thing about working in news
is that nothing is the same for very
long
and you're always trying to um to keep
on top of latest developments different
stories
follow up an idea you had so i think
it cheesy as it sounds i love my job and
that really helps
and also the the constant time pressure
um
makes can make you very productive
i've got to echo what victoria said you
know i love my job and i love
news and i love telling stories so you
know
there are there are so many stories out
there and i just want to be able to
tell as many as i possibly can so you
you just constantly keep digging and you
constantly
want to get on air telling telling those
stories so
i think that's one one key thing of
being uh
motivated but also i think it's
important to say as well
competitors you know we we've got
competitors in this industry
and you see people from other
organizations doing stories and you
think oh actually that's quite
that's quite a good story or you know
that's quite a good angle and
it kind of motivates you to want to be
able to
do something for for your organization
and to make sure that
you know people are are clicking on the
website
of your organization of sky and people
are watching sky news and
and are getting their news from us and i
think that also plays
a key role as well because you know i
could bring in one story
which could bring in you know a dozen a
new
people who've never watched sky news
before and then they start exploring all
the other things that we've got
to offer and then they stick with us and
that's quite a nice feeling if you know
that that's going on as well okay um
another question please natalie
i think this is the last question um
what is your best piece of advice for
somebody looking to start out a career
in journalism
um peter may i ask you that first
yes i think at the somewhere near the
beginning of this
session i think i probably answered a
similar question i i do think that
the most important thing if you're
contemplating a career in journalism
is to really really believe in it to
really believe that that is
absolutely definitely what you want to
do because you have the right
amount of curiosity about what's going
on in the world
what's going on in the country and that
you want to be the person
who's telling those stories revealing
those truths
and so on so i think the the biggest
asset you can have is
it's your curiosity and interest in in
the job
and you need you know as i think i said
earlier you need to have strong
communication skills and i think that
it's very difficult to be a journalist
if you don't have good uh written skills
as well aisha somebody who's relatively
new to skype
what would your advice be
um i'd say the first thing don't panic
don't stress take your time with all of
it
um ask lots of questions because that
will definitely help you out
um at the time and later down the line
um
but yeah just with the apprenticeship
the best thing is it's so flexible so
really
um whenever you get such an opportunity
make the most of it try as much as you
can
um to really build some strong
foundations
easy um for me
it's just be yourself always be yourself
never
be different because you'll get caught
out if you change the way that you speak
if you uh are different you know a
different person in the newsroom to
what you know what you are outside i
just think it's so important to
be true to yourself tell the story um
in in in your own way don't try and kind
of
make it sound you know more kind of
extravagant or anything
like that um just just be very true to
yourself and also be extremely driven i
think
if you've got a target if you've got a
goal you know find your
zigzag stat steps to get to get to that
goal
and just be focused to get there and and
you will joe joe
i'd say work hard and be nice to
everyone and obviously be nice to work
experience because they'll
soon like lindsay was a be sort of star
reporter
in a sort of later career and i think
being nice to everyone is really
important i think
um certainly in politics you might think
that the important people
are the people you should really be
paying attention to but actually
um i think it's really important to talk
to absolutely everybody in your
workplace the people on reception the
people
on security because they also always
have a story or an insight of what's
happening they see things you don't
and one really good example perhaps in
covet about
talking to everyone being nice for
everyone is the cleaners we work with
because they have a different shift
pattern to a lot of us they're getting
on public transport
at a different time and therefore when
we were trying to work out who was
wearing a mask on public transport
and who isn't our key sources were
actually um
our cleaners in western and therefore
everybody's
insight and story you need to think
about um
work hard but really pay attention to
every single person you come into
contact with
not the people who you think are
important for now and
might yeah victoria final thought from
you
i would say be tenacious be persistent
be
stubborn whether that is um
when you're first starting out and
you're trying to get your foot in the
door anywhere
or whether that's with a story i think
that's a key a key trait for a
journalist
because it can be difficult there can be
obstacles it's competitive
and you just have to keep going and it
can be it's
um a fast fast-paced and competitive
industry but there's lots of jobs out
there and lots of different kinds of
jobs
within journalism and just keep going
it can be difficult when you start but
we've all been there
people are understanding there's lots of
opportunities just
just keep going and once you start to
get a bit of momentum
it gets easier and easier and that trait
is
is crucial will be crucial throughout
your journalism career don't
don't um let setbacks put you off keep
going keep trying to find that perfect
case study
that story that filming location
okay guys victoria aisha
uh insanely joe and the peter
thank you so much for uh showing us
giving us a glimpse of what you do
and joining us um this this morning in
virgo conference the afternoon
uh here on our sky knees virtual tour
good to see you
see you all again soon um and that is it
thank you for joining us on our sky news
virtual tour i really do hope you've
learned a little bit about
our business how it works the different
departments the different elements i
mean my final thought would be
that it's a great place to work it's
exciting
it's diverse it comes with lots of
energy
and it's really time consuming and yes
you know in the early stages you will
work
unsociable hours you'll work christmases
and birthdays and all that kind of thing
but it's a wonderful wonderful industry
to work in
when there's a big breaking story
there's a garth in the newsroom and
there's all hands on deck and
everybody's pulling in the same
direction
for an ultimate goal serving our viewers
serving our customers so journalism it's
a great
place to work um and i say there are
loads of ways of different
of getting into the industry there's no
hard and fast rule
but if you work hard if you're committed
if you're focused
if you can establish um contacts and
build your contacts
based it's a really good grounding for
getting yourself
in the industry and making the way the
very best of luck with you
all the best look after yourselves bye